ZDF heute live schön dass ihr dabei seid
für die israelischen Geiseln in der
Gewalt der Hamas gibt es offenbar
Hoffnung seit Stunden warten Angehörige
und Freunde der Geiseln in Tel Aviv auf
Details zu einem Deal den es zwischen
der Terrororganisation Hamas und der
israelischen Armee zu dessen der
israelischen Regierung zu dessen zu
deren Freilassung geben soll direkt
neben an im Verteidigungsministerium
trifft sich in diesen Minuten das
israelische Kabinett um über
Einzelheiten zu beraten ja seit Wochen
wurde verhandelt jetzt soll es eben
einen Deal geben mehrere Medien
berichten übereinstimmt mehr als 50
israelische Geiseln Frauen und Kinder
sollen freikommen im Gegenzug sei eine
mehrtägige Feuerpause vereinbart worden
ja was ist stand jetzt noch über diesen
Deal bekannt zu welchem Preis kommen die
israelischen Geiseln jetzt frei und was
bedeutet das für die israelische
Offensive und den weiteren Verlauf des
Krieges und was ist mit den Geiseln die
jetzt eben noch nicht freikommen sollen
dazu schalten wir gleich nach Tel Aviv
zu meinem zu unserem ZDF Korrespondenten
Michael beverunge und ich spreche mit
iriris schalik er ist Sprecher des
israelischen Militärs und auch im Stream
der ehemalige Unterhändler Gerhard
Konrad der selbst einmal zwischen der
Hamas und der israelischen Regierung
vermittelt hat eure Fragen und Gedanken
zum Thema könnt ihr wie immer sehr gerne
hier direkt im Chat stellen und mit uns
teilen oder ihr schickt sie uns per Mail
an
zdfheute-li@zf.de und ich versuche dann
so viele wie möglich davon hier im
Stream unterzubringen wir wollen jetzt
zu beginnen einmal nach Tel Aviv
schalten zu meinem Kollegen Michael
beverunge um uns auf den aktuellen Stand
bringen zu lassen hallo Michael grüß
Dich hallo also erst hat sich heute das
kriegskabinett in Israel getroffen dann
das Sicherheitskabinett und jetzt sitzt
eben in diesen Minuten das gesamte
Kabinett Zusam dabei soll es wohl vor
allem um Details zu diesem Deal gehen
mit der Hamas welche Informationen hast
du dazu
aktuell vielleicht noch ganz kurz zur
Einordnung wo wir hier stehen weil es
ist ein Ort wo sich seit Wochen die
Angehörigen der geisenn versammeln und
hier allerlei Installationen aufbauen
die an das Schicksal der Geisel erinnern
sollen der Schicksal der Geisel
wachhalten soll hier ist z.B eine Tafel
wo jeden Abend die Kerzen angezündet
werden äh die soll erinnern dass 240
Menschen eben fehlen an dieser Tafel
teilweise sind hier Puppen Spielzeuge
von kleinen Kindern die auch besonders
an das Schicksal der kleinen Kinder
erinnern sollen und äh da sind wir auch
schon genau beim Problem äh dass es
diesen Deal geben wird direkt hier auf
der anderen Straßenseite ist das
Verteidigungsministerium da tagt gerade
das ganze Kabinett es gibt noch keinen
offiziellen Beschluss aber klar ist sie
werden einen geiseldeal absegnen aber
wie sieht der genau aus z.B sind
tatsächlich alle 40 vermissten Kinder
die bei den Geiseln in Gaza sein sollen
sind die dabei da heißt es
wahrscheinlich sind es nur 30 weil zehn
möglicherweise nicht in der Hand der
Hamas sondern in der Hand des Islamic
Jihad ist dann ist die Frage wie viele
andere Personen wie viele Frauen werden
auf einmal dabei sein werden es am
Anfang 50 oder mehr Personen sein
es wird so sein dass das Verhältnis
ungefähr von den israelischen Geiseln zu
den ausgetauschten Gefangenen den
palästinensischen Gefangenen in den
israelischen Gefängnissen ein:3 sein
soll also proisraelische Geisel drei
Gefangene aus den israelischen
Gefängnissen und das soll jeweils an
einem Tag erfolgen immer systematisch
zehn Geiseln vielleicht für israelische
Gefangene im Austausch eben für die
anderen Geiseln und dann am nächsten Tag
wieder und sofort und S fort wie lange
diese Waffenpause dauern soll an der
dann immer diese äh austausche
stattfinden soll das ist auch unklar
sind es vier Tage sind es fünf Tage also
sind noch eine Menge Fragen offen und
auch die Menschen hier warten darauf
dass es am Ende dieser Kabinettssitzung
ein offizielles vielleicht Statement
geben wird was den nun tatsächlich die
Details dieses Gefangenen Deals sind du
hast jetzt schon gesagt die Details das
ist noch in weiten Teilen unklar gibt es
trotzdem schon Informationen darüber du
hast gesagt die Geiseln werden
möglicherweise dann tageeise in
kleineren Gruppen freigelassen wann das
passieren soll auch die jetzt von dir
schon angesprochene Waffenruhe
mhm ist auch eine wichtige Frage denn
das wird nicht sofort morgen passieren
äh hier das ist immerhin noch ein
Rechtsstaat und äh es gibt die
Möglichkeit Widerspruch einzulegen das
sind immerhin verurteilte Straftäter zum
Teil in den Gefängnissen äh und es gibt
die Möglichkeit Widerspruch einzulegen
allerdings nur für einen Tag
äh es ist auch wenig wahrscheinlich dass
dieser Widerspruch angenommen wird weil
es hier um einen höheren Zweck geht eben
israelische Geiseln aus der
Gefangenschaft in Gasa zu befreien aber
es wird wahrscheinlich noch ein bis zwei
Tage dauern bevor dieser tageweise
Mechanismus überhaupt in Gang kommt mhm
du hast die Feuerpause auch angesprochen
die ist ein Zugeständnis an die Hamas
welche anderen Zugeständnisse musste die
israelische Regierung der Hamas denn
machen für diesen Deal darüber
hinaus
mhm ja ein etwas kurios anmutendes
Zugeständnis nämlich dass pro Tag in der
Feuerpause für 6es Stunden die
drohnenüberwachung abgestellt wird das
hat wahrscheinlich vor allem den
Hintergrund weil die Geiseln müssen ja
irgendwo wahrscheinlich aus den Tunnel
an die Oberfläche gebracht werden und
die hammas fürchtet dass die Israelis
entdecken könnten dass quasi
wenn die Geiseln herausgeführt werden
dass man sie beobachtet und ein Hinweis
auf die stecke der Geiseln geben wird
die dann später vielleicht mit Gewalt
aufgesucht werden könnten ist denn schon
klar dazu gab es jetzt auch schon
verschiedene Berichte wo genau ob diese
Feuerpause dann für den ganzen
gaserstreifen gilt oder beispielsweise
nur für den
Süden nein diese vuerpause wird für den
gesamten gaserstreifen gelten das ist
klar und
wenn denn diese dieser
austauschmechanismus tatsächlich
funktioniert dann könnte das
möglicherweise sie Blaupause sein für
einen weiteren Austausch das Kabinett so
ist zu hören wird nicht etwa den
Austausch von 150 Gefangenen in den
Gefängnissen sondern vielleicht sogar
schon für 300 Gefangene autorisieren
sodass man nicht noch mal einen extra
Beschluss machen müsste wenn denn
weitere Geiseln freigelassen werden von
der Hammers Michael uns erreicht eine
Frage bei Facebook und zwar gab es denn
Vermittler in diesem Prozess hin zu
einem geiseldeal und welche Staaten
waren bisher maßgeblich daran beteiligt
was kannst du uns dazu
sagen also mit Sicherheit sind mehr
Staaten beteiligt gewesen zu allererst
Qatar die ein sehr gutes Verhältnis zur
Hamas pflegen auch immer wieder die
Hamas über Jahr weg mit großen
millionenummen unterstützt haben die USA
werden eine große Rolle gespielt haben
aber weitere Teil Details sind mir
jedenfalls nicht bekannt es gibt auch
Berichte D durch diesen jetzt z.B auch
Lebensmittel und Treibstoff in den
Gasastreifen geliefert werden können wir
haben in den vergangenen Wochen auch
immer wieder über die ja sehr
katastrophale Lage vor allem für die
Zivilbevölkerung im gaserstreifen
berichtet welche Auswirkung hätte dieser
Deal denn für die Zivilisten im
Gasastreifen und für die humanitäre Lage
dort
möglicherweise ja das ist tatsächlich
sehr wichtig auch die humanitäre Hilfe
soll erhöht werden das war auch lange
Zeit sehr sehr umstritten vor allem
welche Mengen an Treibstoff sollen in
den Gasastreifen geliefert werden weil
die Israelis Angst haben dass die
ohnehin nur von der Hamas abgegriffen
werden jetzt soll tatsächlich die Menge
des Treibstoffes auch deutlich erhöht
werden und ungefähr eine Zahl zwischen
100 und 50 2 LKWs täglich auch mit
anderen Lebensmitteln unter anderen
ausrüstungs Gegenständen sollen jetzt
täglich dann in diesen Tagen in den
gaserstreifen
Rollen über die Situation der anderen
Geiseln oder der Geiseln generell im
gaserstreifen war ja in den vergangenen
Wochen nicht viel bekannt es gab immer
wieder einzelne Berichte von Personen
die dann freigelassen wurden was welche
Informationen hast du zu den Geiseln
gibt es da überhaupt irgendwelche
Information zu den Geisel die jetzt noch
in der Gewalt der Hamas
sind nein es gibt nicht sehr viele
Informationen interessant ist vielleicht
auch
eigentlich hatten die auch die
Angehörigen versucht ja eine
Kategorisierung also Unterscheidung in
Geiseln mit israelischer
Staatsangehörigkeit Geisel mit doppelter
Staatsangehörigkeit Deisel die
vielleicht amerikanische
Staatsbürgerschaft die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft haben zu
unterscheiden dieser Deal wird so ist zu
hören lediglich Geiseln mit israelischer
Staatsbürgerschaft umfassen und die
Aussage ist dass die anderen Staaten
selbst versuchen müssen einen Austausch
eine Freilassung zu erreichen aber über
den Zustand der Geiseln da ist bisher
eigentlich überhaupt nichts
bekannt alles klar vielen dank Michael
beverunge live aus Tel Aviv wir sprechen
uns später noch mal du beobachtest die
Lage dort für uns weiter und dann lassen
wir uns gerne später noch mal von dir
auf den aktuellsten Stand bringen danke
für den Moment ich kann jetzt gleich
sprechen mit eire schalika er ist
Sprecher des israelischen Militärs und
von ihm wollen wir uns jetzt einmal
anhören wie denn dieser Deal aus der
Perspektive des israelischen Militärs
gesehen wird und und der ist mir jetzt
zugeschaltet hallo Herr schalika grüße
sie Shalom aus Israel ihre Regierung
sitzt aktuell noch zusammen über die
Details des Deals wird offenbar noch
gesprochen verhandelt von meinem
Kollegen haben wir schon erste Infos
gehört eine Feuerpause ist wohl Teil des
Deals jetzt liegt die Vermutung nah dass
die Hamas diese Feuerpause eben auch
nutzen wird um sich neu zu sortieren
Kräfte zu bündeln welches
Gefahrenpotential oder welche
Auswirkungen sehen Sie konkret durch
diesen
Deal ja also Sie haben es zum einen
schon richtig angesprochen dass
derartige di natürlich auch Gefahren mit
sich bringen und dafür muss das Militär
natürlich vorbereitet sein aber im
Endeffekt entscheidet der Staat und die
Regierung entscheidet und wir sind
natürlich glücklich über jeden
diplomatischen Erfolg im Endeffekt geht
est es uns um um die Menschen um das
Menschenleben retten und wenn Menschen
ikommen über diplomatische Kanäle dann
wird das Militär natürlich da auch in
dieser Situation sage ich jetzt mal
äh warten und der hoffen das Beste
hoffen nach wie vor Menschen sich
natürlich in Geiselhaft befinden da die
militärische Option weiterhin aufrecht
zu erhalten okay Herr schallika wir
hatten da jetzt kurze technische
Tonaussetzer dafür einmal sorry an
dieser Stelle ich würde sie trotzdem
gerne noch mal fragen sie haben gerade
gesagt also sie sehen dadurch durchaus
Gefahren durch diesen Deal was könnte
das konkret bedeuten eine Feuerpause für
sie ja also es ist die Hamas
Terrororganisation tut der israelischen
ja keinen Gefallen wenn sie jetzt eine
Feuerpause bittet sondern sie möchte
diese Feuerpause zum einen um sich neu
zu positionieren natürlich um ein Stück
weit wieder atmen zu können aus ihren
tunnelnetzwerken von A nach B sich zu
bewegen Raketen neu zu positionieren en
eventuell auch Geiseln die restlichen
Geiseln von A nach B von B nach C zu
verschleppen eventuell sogar auch aus
dem Hinterhalt israelische Soldaten die
in diesem Nischen gaserstreifen nach
wieor Vorort sind eventuell auch
anzugreifen das sind alles Optionen die
wir natürlich vor Augen uns halten
müssen mit der Hoffnung trotzdem weil
Menschen leben uns sehr viel wert ist
dass Menschen über diplomatische Kanäle
rausgelassen werden freigelassen werden
und das ist alles was zählt im
Endeffekt glauben Sie dass es dadurch
auch möglicherweise wieder zu
verstärkten auch Raketenangriffen aus
dem Gazastreifen auf Israel kommen
könnte ja also aus der Vergangenheit
haben wir natürlich gelernt dass man
einer Terrororganisation in keinster
Weise vertrauen kann und sie natürlich
alles zu ihrem Gunsten nüzen ob das
Krankenhäuser sind oder Schulen oder
Moscheen oder auch Feuerpausen und
natürlich hatten wir in der
Vergangenheit schon in anderen Operation
Visa wieder Hamas Situation wo wir einer
Feuerpause zugestimmt haben und dann
genau in den Tagen der Feuerpause die
Hamas aus dem Hinterhalt des Feuer
eröffnet hat Soldaten getötet hat und
Soldaten verschleppt hat in mitten einer
Feuerpause und das kann natürlich auch
dieses mal passieren dass entweder
innerhalb des gaserstreifens etwas
passiert oder aber auch Raketen auf
Israel abgeschossen werden und dann
natürlich wir uns wieder in einer neuen
Situation befinden jetzt ist dieser Deal
diese Vereinbarung ja ganz klarare
Zeichen für diplomatische Bemühung die
es aktuell gibt es ist jetzt aber davon
auszugehen wir haben es gehört es sind
vor allem Frauen und Kinder die jetzt
freikommen also sozusagen humanitäre
Fälle auch wie wollen Sie denn die
anderen Geiseln die ja möglicherweise
natürlich ist jedes Menschenleben gleich
viel wert aber aus der Sicht der Hamas
sind ja sicher da noch Geiseln
in Gefangenschaft die ja ein höheres
eine höhere strategische Wichtigkeit
haben wie wollen sie die denn befreien
zusätzlich zu den diplomatischen
Bemühungen die es jetzt gerade
gibt also zum einen das sind zwei Kanäle
die parallel laufen das der
diplomatische kan Kanal über den ich
natürlich nichts
wir sagen kann weil ich nicht Teil der
Diplomatie
bin davon muss man ausgehen mithört wir
haben aber unsere W natürlich seit dem
ja entschuldigen sie darf ich da noch
einmal reingehen weil wir hatten jetzt
gerade da massive tonaussätze darf ich
Sie noch einmal bitten die Antwort zu
wiederholen weil es ist leider bei mir
und bei den Zuschauern glaube ich nichts
angekommen ja ich entschuldige mich zum
einen äh also erstmal wir müssen
natürlich die diplomatischen Kanäle
damit habe ich ja persönlich nichts zu
tun weil das ist ja Diplomatie und ich
bin im Militär äh und deshalb müssen wir
die militärische Option nach wie vor äh
immer im Auge behalten und da natürlich
seit dem 7 Oktober wir sehr bemüht sind
jede Information jedes Puzzelstück zu
sammeln über den Aufenthaltsort der
Geisel um dann natürlich wenn es wieder
dann losgehen sollte und es wird wieder
losgehen mit oder ohne Feuerpause dann
angenommen wenn es eine Feuerpause gibt
dann nach vier oder 5 Tagen sowieso weil
ein Großteil der Geisel auch in so einem
Deal fallser stattfinden sollte nicht
freigelassen werden und wir werden
weitermachen bis wir alle Menschen aus
den händ der Terroristen befreien Herr
schik sie haben jetzt gerade auch noch
mal gesagt wie witig solche
diplomatischen Bemühungen sind eben auch
um da möglichst viele Menschenleben zu
schützen sie sind seit Wochen in dem
Dilemma als israelisches Militär auf der
einen Seite die Geiseln befreien und
Zivilbevölkerung zu schützen und auf der
anderen Seite verfolgen sie ihr
erklärtes Ziel die Hamas zu zerschlagen
es ist jetzt aber auch immer wieder
Kritik in den vergangenen Wochen laut
geworden dass die Zivilbevölkerung im
Gazastreifen eben nicht ausr ausreichend
geschützt wird wie wollen Sie das
möglicherweise in Zukunft besser machen
na ja also es ist natürlich fürs
israelische Militär eine Mammuts
auffgabe dass wir Menschen auf beiden
Seiten der Grenze beschützen müssen und
das ist in einem normalen Krieg
eigentlich nicht der Fall in einem
normalen Krieg beschützt jede Seite
jedes Militär nur die Menschen auf der
eigenen Seite der Grenze in diesem Fall
versucht Hamas Menschen auf beiden
Seiten zu töten und wir versuchen
Menschen auf beiden Seiten zu retten das
ist eine absurde Situation in der wir
uns befinden und deswegen wir langsam
besondnen und mit äußerster präzisität
Vorgehen sage ich mal wir versuchen so
präzise wie möglich vorzugehen nur
Terroristen treffen was in so einer
Situation aus dicht besiedelten Gebieten
von wo geschossen wird eigentlich kaum
möglich ist dennoch über die humanitären
Korridore natürlich Menschen in
Sicherheit bringen damit die Kampfzone
sage ich jetzt mal größtenteils
von Zivilisten befreit ist damit wir
dann als israelisches Militär in erster
Linie Terroristen gegenüber stehen sagt
eire schallika Sprecher des israelischen
Militärs vielen Dank für Ihre Antworten
für die Zeit heute Abend und die
technischen Probleme und kleinen
Tonaussetzer bitten wir an dieser Stelle
jetzt noch einmal zu
entschuldigen so wir wollen jetzt noch
einmal über diesen Deal zwischen der
israelischen Regierung und der Hamas
sprechen und auch die Frage stellen wie
der denn einzuordnen ist und welche
Chancen es jetzt noch für die
verbleibenden Geisel gibt die
möglicherweise im Zuge dieses dials
jetzt nicht freikommen das kann ich
jetzt besprechen mit Gerhard er der hat
lange auch für den
Bundesnachrichtendienst gearbeitet und
er weiß aus erster Hand wie solche
verandlungen ablaufen guten Abend Herr
Konrad ja guten Abend Herr Wortmann ich
will unseren Zuschauern gerne noch
einmal sagen sie waren auch mal
Vermittler bei Verhandlung zu
Geiselbefreiung unter anderem auch
zwischen Israel und der Hamas dabei ging
es um die Freilassung des israelischen
Soldaten gelat schalid der nach 5 Jahren
im Austausch gegenüber 100 gegenüber
1000 palästinensische Palästinenser
freikam sie haben die Meldung die es
jetzt im Laufe des Nachmittags zu diesem
möglichen Deal gab auch verfolgt wie ist
dieser Deal aus ihrer Sicht einzuordnen
ist das ein Erfolg aus israelischer
Sicht ja sag mal es ist zumindest mal
ein Erfolg für die betroffenen Menschen
das ist ganz klar und
wenn sich die Zahlen einigermaßen
bestätigen sollten äh dann handelt es
sich ja in der Tat um 50 vielleicht bis
bis 70 besonders äh schwerwiegende
humanitäre Fälle mit der Option wie auch
schon erwähnt word ist in einem zweiten
Durchgang etwas später noch einmal
vielleicht 50 Personen zu begünstigen
damit wären dann um die 100 120 Geißeln
von mutmaßlich 240 frei das wäre wenn es
so kommen sollte ein
äh wichtiger großer Teilerfolg den
sollte man dann auch nicht klein reden
klar ist äh dass mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit die schwierigen Fälle
die wirklich schwierigen Fälle nämlich
jene Personen in äh Israel die wegen
Terrorismus Vergehen verhaftet und
verurteilt worden sind von diesem Deal
nicht betroffen sind und umgekehrt
natürlich auch von is bei den
israelischen Geiseln
alle
Militärpersonen und andere vielleicht
aus Hamas Sicht bedeutsamen Personen
zurückgehalten werden wir werden also
auf jeden Fall eine zweite ungleich
schwierigere härtere Phase von
Verhandlungen haben wahrscheinlich erst
einmal eingeleitet durch einen weiteren
Waffengang das muss befürchten mhm uns
erreicht gerade eine Frage bei Youtube
von Chris WZ kann man denn überhaupt
davon ausgehen dass sich die Hamas
Terroristen an diese Vereinbarung halten
werden oder gibt es möglicherweise
Splittergruppen wird gefragt es gibt
wohl auch Splittergruppen das mag jetzt
am Anfang noch nicht die Rolle spielen
derzeit kann Hamas wenn wir Hamas nur
nehmen und nicht noch den Palestinian
Islamic Jihad das sind ja die beiden
Gruppierung wobei Hamas die deutlich
größere ist äh die Hamas kann sich
derzeit allein schon deswegen an ihre
Verpflichtungen handeln weil sie über
Personen verhandelt die in ihrer Gewalt
sind das würde beim zweiten oder dann
spätestens beim dritten Durchgang
schwieriger werden wenn es vielleicht um
alle noch in Gaza verbliebenen Geiseln
sich handelt und dann die bange Frage
auftacht wo sind die denn alle in wessen
Hand sind die kan heramas sozusagen die
restlichen vielleicht versprengten
Geiseln denn überhaupt sammel
s dass man hinterher mit Zuversicht
sagen kann ja das sind jetzt alle also
das wird noch mal eine ganz prekäre auch
praktische Frage sein die stellt sich
aber erst gegen Ende des gesamten
Verhandlungsprozesses also in Wochen
oder Monaten je nachdem oder noch länger
wir haben von meinem Kollegen Michael
bwerunge aus telaviv jetzt schon gehört
sozusagen welche Zugeständnisse die
israelische Regierung der Hamas denn
machen musste für diesen Deal wie hoch
schätzen Sie den Preis aus israelischer
Perspektive ein den die Regierung eben
dafür zahlen muss
ja jetzt kurzfristig ist das zwar
natürlich ungleichgewichtig wenn sie
sagen 50 Geiseln gegen unter 50
Häftlinge
man hat schon schlechtere Relationen
gesehen das eigentlich Interessante auch
für Hamas ist derzeit die Feuerpause
die Häftlinge das sind jetzt auch Frauen
und Kinder das ist zwar lobenswert aber
aus Hamas Sicht ich meine mich da noch
gut an die Gespräche und Verhandlungen
zu erinnern die ich geführt habe vor
Jahren äh entscheidend wird es sein aus
Hamas Sicht später die Kämpfer wenn es
geht die Prominenten Kämpfer also aus
israelischer Sicht die erzterroristen
freizupressen die weiterhin in
israelischen Gefängnissen bleiben also
die der Härtetest kommt noch äh und
jetzt ist es in der Tat stärker ein
emotionaler humanitärer Aspekt auf
beiden Seiten nicht Frauen und Kinder
genießen auch bei Herr Maß eine gewisse
verbale Privilegierung zumindest es ist
nach muslimischenem Verständnis auch
schwererträglich muslimische Frauen und
Kinder in feindlicher Hand zu haben also
insofern haben wir hier im gröbsten
Sinne vergleichbare Vorstellungen
deswegen fällt das noch vergleichsweise
leicht mhm hat sich aus ihrer
Einschätzung ihrer Einschätzung nach
denn durch diesen Deal der jetzt da
möglicherweise bevorsteht die Position
der Hamas eher geschwächt gestärkt kann
man das irgendwie sagen ja sie hat sie
sie hat sich relativ gestärkt undter dem
Aspekt ja wir sind wieder im
Verhandlungsprozess wir sind ein W sind
nicht nur ein Kriegsgegner oder ein zu
vernichtendes etwas sondern wir sind
Verhandlungspartner wir reden über
Vermittler mit der Außenwelt insofern
eine gewisse reetablierung des Status
den man auch früher schon hatte sie
dürfen nicht vergessen dass die letzten
Wochen im Wesentlichen nur davon
gekennzeichnet waren dass man von
israelischer Seite Hamas eben
eliminieren möchte auslöschen möchte
jetzt muss man mit ihnen reden ne das
ist wenn sie wollen ein ein
Achtungserfolg aus Hamas Sicht äh die
Feuerpausen werden in der Tat mit
Sicherheit genutzt werden äh um sich ein
kleines bisschen zu äh erholen es kann
auch durchaus sein das müssen wir sehen
äh ob äh eine Sequenzierung solcher
solcher äh
austauschoperationen dazu führen könnte
aus hamß Sicht eine Feuerpause an die
andere anzuschließen
äh umäh wesentlich längere äh
Erholungsphasen vorzunehmen unklar ist
das müssen wir eingestehen unklar ist
aus uns Sicht aus meiner Sicht das
Endgame aus Hamas Perspektive wo will
Hamas hin nicht ich meine sie dürfen
nicht vergessen Hamas hat erstmal den
halben gasstreifen verloren Hamas steht
unter militärischem Druck die
Perspektiven die militärischen
Perspektiven für Hamas isoliert
betrachtet sind nicht glänzend nicht ums
mal höflich auszudrücken nicht sie
können sich vielleicht behaupten sie
können sich eingraben im Win des Wortes
aber mehr ist da nicht drin sie müssen
also Hamas muss auf Verhandlungswege und
über Verbündete in der Region und
international auch unfrei ige Verbündete
wenn Sie wollen muss Einfluss nehmen um
sich selber aus der Ecke wieder
herauszum manövrieren ob sie das schafft
ist eine andere Frage ja das heißt Sie
müssen dafür sorgen Sorge tragen dass
Israel in seinen militärischen
Bemühungen Hamas eben auszulöschen sage
ich jetzt mal
behindert wird und an ihrem an der
Durchsetzung dieses Zieles auch
verhindert wird sie haben es gerade
schon bisschen angesprochen wie diese
Verhandlung jetzt weitergehen könnten
war das denn jetzt verhältnismäßig
leicht bzw das was da jetzt noch auf uns
zukommt auf auf die Verhandlung
zukommt ist das sozusagen deutlich
schwieriger was da jetzt bevorsteht bzw
anders gefragt welche Forderungen
könnten die Hamas den da jetzt noch
stellen also beispielsweise
Sicherheitsgarantien oder wo worüber
reden wir da möglicherweise in ein paar
Wochen das wird die Spann wirklich die
spannende Frage sein also rein linear
können Sie sagen wenn her ist maximale
Forderung bei der Freilassung von von
Gefangenen fordern qualitativ und
quantitativ das ist erst der Anfang aber
sie haben völlig recht damit ist
natürlich für Hamas selbst noch nicht
eine Existenz Zusicherung ja oder ein
Status verbunden das wird noch mal eine
ganz harte Nuss sein da muss ich Ihnen
sagen das ist derzeit noch gar nicht
absehbar ob das dann in eine exilformum
gehen soll kann Hamas überhaupt wieder
nach Gaza zurückkehren kann sich Hamas
in südgasa halten als eine politisch
schrägich militärische Kraft nach
heutigem Stand der Dinge sieht das sehr
unwahrscheinlich aus ja aber dann heißt
es natürlich wohin ja mit der
hamasführung wenn Israel sich nicht mit
seiner Zielsetzung durchsetzt die
hamasführung ins Jenseits zu befördern
dann ist die Frage wohin Aufnahme
bereite Länder werden wahrscheinlich
nicht allzu viele zu finden sein Herr
Konrad ich würde gerne noch eine Frage
weitergeben an sie die wir bei Youtube
bekommen haben und zwar was sind das
denn für Gefangene Palästinenser stehen
die der Hamas nah oder warum sind die in
Israel inhaftiert was was können Sie
dazu sagen ja ja das ist ein ganz
breites Spektrum deswegen spricht man
auch ganz gerne von
sicherheitshäftlingen das geht sage ich
jetzt mal von einem Administrativhaft
befindlichen steineerfer sozusagen am
ganz unteren Ende der sag mal
Ordnungswidrigkeit schächr kleine
Straftat bish hin eben zu einem
veritablen Terroristen der mit einer
einem Bombenanschlag oder mit
Schusswaffen eben israelische Zivilisten
vor Jahr und Tag umgebracht hat denn das
sind ja auch noch Häftlinge die schon 20
Jahre oder 25 Jahre Haft iher
lebenslangen oder mehrfach lebenslangen
Haft verbüst haben die jetzt auch schon
in reiferen Alter sind die Hamas
natürlich herauspressen möchte das
hatten wir schon mal vor 12 Jahren in
der alten Verhandlung bei gilardchalid
und das ist dann mit ein prestigeziel
von Hamas diese Terroristen die man
wirklich so benennen kann aufgrund der
Art ihrer Tat äh freiubekommen und
dazwischen haben Sie alle Möglichkeiten
der der der Beihilfe zu Terrorakten der
logistischen Unterstützung alles das
strafwürdige Dinge wie wir Deutschland
z.B auch nach 129a 12 b des
Strafgesetzbuchs haben nicht das können
sie also mehr oder minder
transponieren ja Mitgliedschaft
Unterstützung einer terroristischen
Vereinigung das sind viele dabei die
jetzt nicht im engeren Sinne so würden
die Israelis sagen Blut an den Händen
haben aber die eben anderen Beihilfe
geleistet haben sie unterstützt haben
bei solchen Taten deswegen kommen auch
hohe Zahlen nicht man sprach ja mal
früher von 4in5000 bis 6000 was es jetzt
ist istind ja weiter Verhaftungen
erfolgt weiß ich
nicht wenn wir jetzt noch mal auf die
Gefangenen im Gazastreifen schauen also
die israelischen Geiseln in den in den
Händen der Hamas dazu fragt faler bei
Youtube wie kann man denn eigentlich wie
ist man denn eigentlich noch sicher dass
die Geiseln noch leben kann man da
sicher
sein nein richtig sicher kann man nur
dann oder könnte man man nur dann sein
wenn man über Sensorik ja also über
Wellen ja oder über technische Sensoren
äh einen quantifizierbaren
identifizierbaren
sag Ergebnisse erzielen könnte das kann
ich mir persönlich nicht vorstellen das
wie es so schön heißt das hat es früher
auch nicht gegeben selbst bei gilard
charid wusste man das ja nicht in
Echtzeit deswegen hatten wir ja auch mal
einen Proof of life also ein
lebensbeweis äh zu Beginn meiner
Verhandlungen eingefordert der dann auch
in einem Fall das ist ja bitteschön das
ein Einzelfall gewesen geliefert wurde
über ein Video solche Dinge sind auch
nicht so sehr hilfreich weil sie ja nur
eine Momentaufnahme darstellen nach dem
mor heute geht's ihm oder ihr gut was
ist morgen wissen wir nicht ja also da
nein man weiß es nicht und wenn man es
wüsste wüsste man nicht ob dieses Wissen
Bestand hätte Herr Konrad vielen Dank
für Ihre Antworten heute abend Gerhard
Konrad ehemaliger Unterhändler und
Sicherheitsexperte danke für ihre Zeit
gerne und gutes Glück danke schön wir
wollen jetzt noch mal nach Israel
schalten zu meinem Kollegen Michael
beverunge der ja da vor Ort die
Entwicklung und die Beratung des
Kabinetts für uns verfolgt Michael wie
ist der aktuelle Stand gibt es
Neuigkeiten ja vielleicht noch in zur
Ergänzung zu dem was her Konrad gerade
gesagt hat eben sind die Geiseln
wirklich am Leben wie geht es Ihnen das
wird wohl Teil des Deals sein das ist
aus den kabinettsgesprächen her
ausgedrungen dass das Internationale
Rote Kreuz Zugang zu den anderen Geiseln
die noch nicht befreit werden haben soll
um damit festzustellen wie geht es Ihnen
wie ist ihr Zustand viele von ihnen sind
krank haben chronische Krankheiten
welche sind noch am leben also das soll
es
geben was ist denn darüber hinaus jetzt
noch bekannt was ist nach außen
gedrungen von diesen Verhandlungen an
Dich herangetragen worden wie geht es
jetzt heute Abend noch weiter werden wir
da heute Abend noch Details
hören also ich kann mir vorstellen dass
es nach dieser
Kabinettssitzung eine Art
Pressekonferenz geben wird
wahrscheinlich des engeren Sicherheits
des kriegskabinetts das sind dann nur
der Premierminister der
Verteidigungsminister und der aus der
Opposition dazu gestoßene neue Minister
Benny garnz der Teil dieser
Notstandsregierung dies
Einheitsregierung geworden ist diese
drei werden möglicherweise eine
Pressekonferenz geben vielleicht auch
nur Netanyahu und dann wird man
tatsächlich Details hören ob das aber
heute Abend noch stattfindet oder erst
morgen das kann ich auch noch nicht
sagen Danke dir dann für den Moment
danke dass du das für uns verfolgst und
einordn ist Michael beverunge in Tel
Aviv ja wir werden das natürlich auch
für euch weiter verfolgen soweit hier
jetzt aber für den Moment bei ZDF heute
live wenn ihr da weiter auf dem
laufenden bleiben wollt und aktuelle
Infos haben wollt auch Hintergründe und
Analysen dann schaut gerne vorbei in der
ZDF heute App danke für heute danke fürs
zuschauen und bis zum nächsten
Mal